the new Congress sworn in yesterday is
the most diverse in US history for the
first time there are more than 100 women
in the House of Representatives the
first two Native American women to serve
Deb Holland and Charisse David's shared
an emotional hug after they were sworn
in that was on the floor in the house
Congress also has its first two Muslim
women Ilhan Omar of Minnesota and
Rasheeda to leave of Michigan Omar
tweeted a picture with her father on
Wednesday saying they were returning to
the same airport where they arrived from
a refugee camp 23 years ago
Moammar is also the first Somali
American elected to Congress we visited
her yesterday as she made history in
Capitol Hill there really hasn't been a
moment since this journey began where I
don't really pinch myself and think how
did I get here is this really happening
I feel extremely honored and grateful to
the people of the fifth for having faith
in my ability to represent them
currently in in our country really there
is extreme negative rhetoric against
Muslims immigrants mainly refugees it is
sort of a deliverance of an extreme
counter narrative to to that and it says
you know this country is still a place
of hope people who represent us should
be a reflection and a representation of
all of the communities that they
represent as someone who has seen really
what it means to seek asylum at a border
and to to be received with such
generosity I want to make sure that here
in the United States we understand that
there are other countries who take in so
many people of the world's most paint
people and in the United States we could
do better I think a lot of people
whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican agree that we can do better
and I think that's what's you know it's
supposed to be the people's house just
to be representative and so you're not
only representing your district but
certainly the types of people in the
faces matter and Arizona will have its
first two Republican excuse me first
female senators one Democrat one
Republican Tennessee will have its first
female Republican senator black Marsha
Blackburn so both parties the faces are
changed some very exciting country of
immigrants do so many people say what a
country